Ngày ngưu chi thông tảm, lạnh đạo cán đất anh pháp đất, ita lia, balan, phần lan, cùng chủ tịch
quý bán cho wow ở sức là vong đời lên. Đã a ra tuyên bú chung về của quả nha trước
thêm thật lịch Mỹ ngà tật tế. Để bú khẳng định không thể thấy đổi biên giời của tế vàng
hủ lực vàng hoa biên chủ của quả nha phải có sự thăm ra của kia. Năm phản lạnh thổ chỉ
dễ dễ dễ dàng khi đã cóng bán hoặc giảm càng thẳng của sự.
Hủ tả khẳng định cũng hộ con sức kinh tế, ngoại giao chủ của quả nha và những mạnh kết hợp dựng ngoại giao
hộ chủ kia và gây sự gác nừng bán là những con đường trống dứt xuống đột.
Hẳng thông tình Wall Street Journal cho biết, Hủ vào của quả nha đã trình để sức dương
có đầy là cơ sở thảo lận tại thật lịch Mỹ ngà. Để sất nếu nừng bán phạt thử kiện trước,
chào đổi lạnh thổ vài xong phương và mọi nựng lộ lạnh thổ của quả nha
vài xong phạt game theo bảo đảm anh. Vùng cả năng ra gặp nha tôi. Tổng thống mỹ tôi đang trăm tình
nếu ý tưởng chào đổi lạnh thổ. Sống tổng thống của quả nha vô đồ đi Miy Zeleski ngay mặt bó.
Hẳng định mọi cuy định thủ của quả nha điều không hiểu lực. Thượng định ngà Mỹ sự kiến tổ chức
ngay mấy là thằng tảm tại bán Alasca của Mỹ. Nhà chẳng cũng đang cần nhắc mời ông Zeleski tham dự.